way out there welcome in to another
exciting edition of Market takes I am
your host Dion rabone we are doing this
Live on YouTube uh reporter for the Wall
Street Journal Dion Robert Bowen here we
are doing Market takes man I know you
could have been anywhere in the world
but you were here with me and I
appreciate that listen I hope y'all out
there are ready to nerd out a little bit
because we are going deep into this Q4
GDP report we're gonna break down the
fourth quarter gross domestic product
report on the U.S economy basically that
tells us not only how much the U.S
economy grew in the fourth quarter but
the overall growth for the entire year
we're gonna dig into all that we're
breaking down non-residential fixed
investment we're breaking down inventory
accumulation we are gonna get into this
report uh not only are we going to talk
about the headline numbers from the
report we're also going to talk about
how the GDP report compared to
expectations we're going to get into
some of those Nitty Gritty details
um we are going to talk about the market
reaction of course because everything is
all about the markets the markets are
going to tell us a lot the reaction to
to this report has been very interesting
across a lot of asset classes so we're
going to dig into that and we're going
to of course talk about what this report
on GDP tells us about the future for the
market and for the economy and you know
as always I'll be telling you what to
watch for next the upcoming data and
what's important because you know we're
always looking forward even though this
is backward looking data that's what we
do so without any further Ado let's get
into it
Q4 GDP Rose by 2.9 percent year over
year that was more than expected
economists surveyed by Dow Jones had
expected 2.8 percent increase so 2.9 a
little more than expected but that's
that's not really the big deal from this
report uh for the year we saw GDP grow
2.1 percent uh that is a significant
slowdown from the 5.9 GDP that we saw in
2021 that was the biggest growth in GDP
for a year since 1984. so huge increase
in 2021 not so much sort of falling back
to Trend this or last year in 2022 we
will get into all that in just a minute
I want to talk about a couple of
comments that I've seen and received
since the support came out my man Greg
daco he is the chief Economist at ey the
former Ernst young he says economy caps
2022 with pride but interest 2023 full
of doubts I think that's that really
sums it up in a very succinct uh and
quick pithy way Greg deco that's my man
he spits a lot of knowledge follow him
if you don't keep on track with what he
reports so breaking out looking at the
actual report the GDP report from the
Bureau of economic analysis the
government's report compared to the
third quarter this is a quote the
deceleration in Real GDP in the fourth
quarter primarily reflected a downturn
in exports and decelerations and
non-residential fixed investment state
and local government spending and
consumer spending these movements were
partly offset by an upturn in private
inventory investment in acceleration and
federal government spending and a
smaller decrease in residential fixed
investment Imports decrease less than
the fourth quarter than in the third
quarter a lot of yada yada yada we're
going to break down what all that means
don't worry I'm not just going to throw
words at you non-residential fixed
investment because that was a chief
thing that was pointed out here that is
often considered the most the sector
most critical to sustaining an economic
expansion we are seeing a deceleration
as in a slowing down of non-residential
fixed investment that's why that matters
the Bea putting that near the top of the
report uh it's contr it's considered one
of the most critical sectors for
sustaining an economic expansion as well
as contributing to the longer term
growth of the economy so that's a big
one and we're seeing it start to slow
down three of the main major components
structures equipment intellectual
property so a lot of this
non-residential fixed investment is
building literal buildings uh putting up
structures but it's also just IP ideas
that people are thinking of and how much
they're investing in those that's
declining that is a real thing to look
at and worry about as we move forward
into 2023 private inventory investment
the thing that kind of picked up and
really did a lot of work that is
considered one of the most volatile
components of GDP that's according to
the government the people who put this
survey out themselves it is one of the
most volatile components of the industry
so we know that for a long time
companies have been stockpiling Goods
buying up way more than they need so
they have an enough Supply in case there
are these supply chain issues in case
deliveries aren't coming in because we
know over the past two years there have
been real issues with businesses getting
the things they need so they've been
buying a lot more stuff and just kind of
stockpiling it putting it away not
selling well this contributed a big a
significant amount to GDP in fact
inventory accumulation accounted for
about half of the GDP growth in Q4 GDP
not including inventories was 1.4
percent my man Lou Breen he is the
economic strategist at grw trading he
tells me quote a decline in inventory
accumulation is on the way and that is
likely to be a GDP drag meaning again
when GDP goes down that's what puts us
into a recession we had two consecutive
quarters back to back of GDP declines or
contractions at the beginning of this
year but the strong pickup in Q3 and Q4
has has very much likely kept us out of
recession we are going to talk about all
that in just a few minutes so why does
all this matter well right now we're
seeing seeing an economy that really
clearly grew in 2022 2.1 percent GDP
growth in 2022 despite that slow start
but as we push forward as we ended the
year we didn't really end on a high note
there are some worrisome things to be
looking at
this influences the recession debate
it's very unlikely that the National
Bureau of economic research is going to
declare a recession for 2022 even though
we did have those two negative quarters
of of growth or two quarters of
contraction if you want to get all
technical about it but it's very
unlikely after the strong way that the
economy finished the year that there
will be a recession for 2022 and
especially with the job growth that we
saw even when those quarters were
showing economic contraction however
2023 could be a different story and
we're seeing some signs of that in this
report so the other thing oh before we
before we get ahead of ourselves pce
inflation that's the fed's favored gauge
personal consumption expenditures that
was up 3.2 percent down from 4.3 in the
third quarter so we're seeing inflation
continue to move lower but the core when
you strip out volatile food and energy
prices that's 3.9 that is further away
from the Federal reserve's target
something that they're going to be
watching very closely so there is a lot
in this report that tells you all right
things weren't so bad bad but this is
not necessarily an outright positive so
listen we're going to throw up some
charts on the on the board right here as
you can see on your screen this is the
GDP going back 10 years I wanted to put
this on the screen to kind of give you
some ideas of what we're what we've been
seeing in the long-term trends so you
see all those big numbers that big spike
up there in 2020 the big spike down
before the Big Spike up and then in 2021
where we had the highest GDP growth in a
year since 1984. you see those numbers
much higher but the last two numbers on
your screen there that's the last two
quarters the third and fourth quarter of
2022 you're seeing us move right back
towards Trend and actually that 2.1
percent GDP number that we that we've
got now for 2022 is right at exactly
where GDP averaged from 2012 to 2021 so
GDP growth average 2.1 percent during
that 10-year period in 2022 it looks
like we stuck right there returning to
growth but with some worrisome signs
that GDP could would be falling and
shrinking we actually saw an increase in
Q3 GDP up to 3.2 percent after those two
negative quarters so a good sign of
recovery but some worrisome signs on the
way and and really like I said it's very
unlikely the National Bureau of economic
research in ber in Bur if you're a big
nerd is going to call declare a
recession for 2022. now this brings us
into 2023. look the most interesting
piece of this report as I said is those
inventory numbers businesses stockpiling
a bunch more things than they need not
really selling them they're not Goods
that they're buying to then sell
immediately they're Goods they're buying
so they've got stuff in the warehouse
stuff in the store so that when
customers come in they're not out of
goods that is likely to slow and without
those inventories we're seeing GDP
growth well below Trend and we're seeing
GDP GDP growth really slow down that
creates a lot of worries about potential
recession uh the most surprising piece
of this report is the way that imports
and exports both decline but you saw
that decrease in Imports as in what
we're buying from other countries and
bringing in decrease more than exports
which is what we're selling out to other
countries imports and exports that has a
real impact on GDP because what we sell
to other countries increases GDP what we
buy from other countries and bring in
that decreases GDP and that played a
major role in this report as well so
again another worrisome sign about the
potential for a recession on the horizon
here in 2023 it's certainly not here but
we have seen a lot of things that tell
us there are reasons to be worried and
look let's step back here really quickly
and talk about the environment coming
into this report we have seen inflation
falling that's a good thing when you
look at the December PPI producer price
index wholesale prices what businesses
are paying for goods we saw that decline
we also saw CPI Consumer Price Index
what you and I are paying when we go to
the grocery store gas station all that
that's declining in a very consistent
way both of those reports in December
were lower than expected so we saw
inflation cool down more than economists
were expecting however on the other side
of that are really kind of on the same
side but the flip side of a good thing
because lower inflation is certainly a
good thing we're paying a lot more money
than we were a year ago for just about
everything
on the other side of that business
growth is very seriously slowing we're
seeing purchasing managers index those
PMI reports from ISM The Institute of
Supply management s p those are showing
some of the lowest readings we've seen
since 2020 right in the midst of the
pandemic when things were just either
starting to open back up or were still
shut down May and June of 2020 those
were not good times for businesses we're
seeing the FED indexes a number of fed
Regional indexes hit lows that we
haven't seen since 2020. again in the
midst of those slowdowns so the Richmond
fed index that came out Tuesday lowest
reading since May 2020. the Empire State
manufacturing survey from the Northeast
region that showed the lowest since
2020. the Philadelphia fed index of
manufacturing again a low rate it
actually picked up from the month before
but near some of those 2020 lows when
things were all locked up when the
economy was shut down that's not good
the latest nabe business conditions
report that's the National Association
of business economists showed quote
wages Rose the majority of respondents
firms in the last three months of 22
2022 and more firms added workers than
reduced head count but far more firms
than in the past three years reported
falling profit margins that is something
to be concerned about as we move into
2023 when folks are talking about what
happened in 2022 also from the nabe
survey for the first time since 2020
more respondents expect falling rather
than increased employment at their firms
in the next three months fewer
respondents than in recent years expect
their firm's Capital spending to
increase in the same period again
business is now saying we think we're
going to spend less going for it we're a
little bit worried about how things are
going we expect to spend less we expect
we're probably gonna have to hire less
people those are all things that are
pushing the economy in sort of this
negative Direction that's got investors
and Market analysts and economists a
little bit worried we're seeing
increased fears about recession and
remember we got that retail sales report
that was negative 1.1 percent for the
month seeing all a lot of a lot of not
all but a lot of these indicators going
down in a solid and sustained way two
levels that we haven't seen since the
midst and some of the worst numbers of
the pandemic job growth also starting to
slow but remember we did see 3.5 percent
unemployment so lots of folks still have
jobs we're not seeing job losses but we
are seeing inflation still high but
coming down but business activity
slowing down notably so listen let's
head to wsj.com and check out the market
what we are seeing from stocks bonds
crypto FX we're seeing the stock market
kind of starting out a little bit lower
at least on the Dow the s p and the
NASDAQ both positive uh we're seeing
basically a saw a strong response you
know the the market started out very
high those pre-market expectations after
this report came out very high but now
we're seeing kind of a Slowdown and a
turn down across the board and indexes
could move negative during the day we
saw back-to-back days of kind of overall
negative days in the market there was a
kind of response hey this GD GDP report
shows the FED wants to see the economy
slowing down if not stalling out that's
a good thing but I think folks are
looking at some of the details these
reports that we've just talked about and
saying ah maybe that's not so great when
we look out at the bond market
I'm talking those those treasury bonds
the government debt well we saw a big
pickup and increase kind of heading into
the report after the report came out you
saw yields on the treasuries really
across the board two-year three-year 5 7
10 30 all pick up now we're seeing those
come back down and what that tells you
is when yields go up prices go down that
means investors are more bullish on the
economy they think all right we're going
to see growth we're going to see
inflation so I want to sell bonds well
we're seeing more buying right now and a
reversal of that term so when folks are
buying bonds it means they're a little
worried about the economy and there
could be some more fears about recession
so we are still seeing bond prices uh
down a little bit on the day but again
that could be a thing where we start to
see bond prices pick up and those yields
come back down on the currency Market
we're seeing the Euro up the dollar down
I'm sorry we're seeing the Euro down the
dollar up overall though the dollar is
up against most other currencies on the
day we have seen a sustained turn down
the dollar as we've seen some weakness
uh as folks think that this inflation's
coming down the fed's going to sort of
slow down on what it's doing you've got
basically a hundred percent of the
market right now predicting a 25 basis
point increase that's a a normal kind of
increase historically slowing down from
they did 50 points uh in December 50
basis points in December 75 the previous
four months before that so generalized
expectations for just a sort of
run-of-the-mill 25 basis point increase
the fed's going to slow its role start
to slow down that's affected the dollar
a lot and you're saying a lot of that
value the dollar come down but again
that could continue if we see worries
about a recession or inflation I'm sorry
if we see worries about a recession
continue that could pick the Dollar's
value right back up crypto is down big
Bitcoin down about two percent ethereum
down about half a percent Ripple down
about two percent as well some of those
bets on risk are really starting to come
off and again you could start to see
stock prices go negative today although
the NASDAQ is really picking up now up
about 0.9 percent listen what this
report says about GDP in the future is
that there are reasons to worry
2022 did not end as badly as feared or
as badly as some of those first couple
quarters suggested it could have we
really avoided likely a recession the
National Bureau of economic research was
going to have the final say but it looks
very likely we will avoid a recession
last year not quite sure about this year
so what to watch next we've got the
University of Michigan consumer
sentiment index that's coming out on
Friday that has been picking up folks as
they're seeing these lower gas prices
and some other lower prices inflations
kind of coming off you're seeing
consumers more excited and more happy
about the economy definitely something
to watch for if that Trend continues or
if that worsens or reverses as people
worry about recession the employment
cost index is out Tuesday the Federal
Reserve will be watching that very
closely as they begin their two-day
policy meeting on the 31st and the first
so that comes out then and then it's fed
meeting day baby we will be right here
doing Market takes I'll be dropping the
knowledge for you right here here I hope
you'll be with me and we'll we'll get
into everything that Fed chair Jerome
pal has to say fed summary of economic
projections all that good stuff so
Market takes Wednesday February 1st be
there be a
that's a square don't do it
um anyway listen I appreciate you being
here with me on Market takes now you
could have been anywhere in the world
but you're here with me I love you for
that be with us next time Wednesday
February 1st when we break down the feds
meeting that's gonna be four o'clock P.M
um and yeah look I look forward to
seeing you next time right here on
Market takes